salut la team menthe à l'eau aujourd'hui
j'ai un challenge contre l'intelligence
artificielle j'ai rendez vous avec
romain de la chaîne techno zone test
avec comme but de faire aussi bien voire
mieux qu'un programme comme akinator et
comment on va faire ça chez lui le mieux
c'est quand même que je vous emmène avec
moi comme romain habitent loin je prends
une autolib c'est même pas une autolib
c'est un four 36° impeccable bon c'est
vrai le trajet un petit peu long alors
comment vachard geek pour meubler ce
trajet de offert des plaques de geek une
blague de geek en général celle là que
seuls les guides comprennent et que même
quand explique pourquoi c'était drôle
je comprends toujours pas pourquoi c'est
drôle où je sais pas ce que ça a donné
pour le son mais je suis obligé d'ouvrir
la fenêtre là les amis ça me change la
vie j'espère juste que ça a pas pourrir
tout le son de la vidéo
et puis c'est bien les blagues ça évite
de s'ennuyer d'ailleurs un guide ne
s'ennuie jamais il se ficher fichiers
dans le même état d'esprit j'en ai avec
trois ingénieurs qui discutent entre eux
sur un salon de l'informatique qui
parlent entre eux et puis le premier dit
voyez moi par exemple quand je sors des
toilettes je fais comme dans la société
chez ingénieur chez microsoft
donc je n'ai pas trop de savon un pas
beaucoup de femmes ont pas beaucoup
d'eau non plus un jeu comme ça je lave
les mains très rapidement donc voilà bon
c'est pas le top de chez top mais au
moins ça coûte pas cher et puis le
deuxième ingénieur dit à moi que ces
divas en moi je suis ingénieur chez
apple et est au contraire comme dans ma
société
quand je sors des toilettes je mets
beaucoup beaucoup de savants jeux lésine
pas je mets beaucoup beaucoup d'eau
alors oui c'est très cher dans le budget
mais il ya quand même une bien meilleure
qualité quoi hélas les deux regarde le
troisième en 10 ans les toits qui
travaillent ou à moi je travaille chez
oracle mais je peux pas vous aider parce
que chez non ce qui se passe sur les
doigts au la petite blague on parle de
pipi
au fait j'ai désolé j'ai ouvert la
chemise mais vraiment pas ce que je suis
en train de cramer
on sait très bien que j'ai pas de
muscles il ya aucune ambiguïté qu il
existe deux types de personnes dans le
monde
ceux qui connaissent le binaire et les
autres
si vous connaissez vous aussi des
blagues un peu petit qui n'est pas à les
mettre en commentaire qu'on a
même si elles sont pas très drôle
n'hésitez pas parce que vous avez comme
point de référence les miennes vous
pourrez pas faire pire que les miennes
en fait que celle que j'ai fait
les mecs après une auto libre trois
trains deux avions un tram et à tous que
j'ai enfin oublier le dromadaire
non j'ai pas pris de dromadaires une
auto lib au départ et il agressé baril
pour l'abus et un coup 2016
j'ai enfin retrouvé romain dont
l'adresse s'affiche nulle part personne
à trouver l'adresse d'ordre c'est bon
boeuf moi c'est bolmon service matin
c'est ça tu m'a appelé et il m'a dit
bouge pas j'arrive
j'ai fait les 06 et jean soûlât ans théo
il faut qu'on leur dise comment ces
rencontres et 300 contre meetup de
pierre cros c'est exact je suis jamais
prôné à la rencontre tu vois je suis
toujours un peu mon le way plus par
internet
après ça dépend youtube etc si vous
organisez mais restez cool moi c'était
le premier me top j'ai jamais fait de 8
heures en fait j'ai même pas ce que
c'était un mythe up quand même a dit bah
tu viens tu bois si tu touches je suis
venu mais voilà c'était voilà c'était
voilà en général ça commence par dessus
bord ouais tu vois et j'ai bien respecté
la règle est on arrivé j'ai dit bon
écoute si david monniaux et tout mais ça
a donné
bah oui bah oui et voilà et c'est un
personnage et ferrat c'est un mec de
confiance deux formations vidéo ensemble
comme toi tu est hyper branché tech
tu dois aimer les intelligences
artificielles ouais ça peut faire
flipper parfois mais ça va être cool à
utiliser bon alors du coup akinator tu
vois et cubains c'est une grosse base de
données qui qui qui qui séquence un
petit peu les réponses
en fait j'aimerais me challenge et des
avis tu vois j'aimerais me poser le
challenge de faire aussi bien voire même
mieux qu'un akinator je suis ainsi ni
donc eu l'intelligence artificielle peut
être plus intelligente que l'homme est
plus rapide plus furtives pas plus d'un
dividende plus efficace plus efficace de
fête noël pilates et c'est plus efficace
qu'un homme certes mais quand on dit que
c'est l'homme qui l'a programmé
exactement c'est bon ça c'est pas de ta
déjà réussi à poser une colle toi avec
l'ina thor ça me dire laquelle je sous
le nom un truc qui l'aurait pas trouvé
je crois oui une fois c'est quand
j'avais trois abonnés du coup personne
ne me connaissait et qui cherche et on
voit là
c'est vrai qu'il l'a pas fait techno des
tests ou techno un test
ça dépend de guaino à la gamme teknion
tests et à chaque fois que le téléphone
d'une techno et s
je fais en mode très french je sais
c'est bien le bonjour monsieur bienvenue
et techno et est entreprise aujourd'hui
des objets rigolos
voilà what the fuck watts de sebasan
avec moi qui vais jouer le rôle d'acn à
tort et toi qui va essayer de me poser
une colle est ce que tu veux qu'on parte
sur gée que de la u par contre ne
oh
jérôme masson a coûté trois billets
d'avion je reviens mais c'est vraiment
pour rentabiliser la vidéo tu vois pas
ce qu en ce moment chez en flux tendu
c'est la vidéo de demain je pas le choix
hockey qui préfèrent un personnage
célèbre célèbre dans le sens où la
majorité des gens doivent le connaître
ouais c'est bon c'est bon
tapie mais n'a pas rompu mais qui est
vraiment à l'ordre je sais où est ce que
tu préfères comparé sur un objet ou un
truc comme ça on va partir sur une
célébrité sur une célébrité donc ça
c'est plus akinator toi les objets c'est
plus le cubain tu voudrais c'est le
cubain non je vais vous mettre en insert
là quelque part c'est une espèce de
petit bac tu peux acheter
ça ressemblait à un tamagotchi géant si
tu veux et oui oui je vois à la boule
oui j'en ai en 20 questions il posait
pas si c'est ça je veux retrouver son
objet c'était le premier truc c'est vrai
que ça a démarré là dessus moi j'avais
adoré ça mais c'était pas mal sa
retraite ça passionnant et sur sur
papier je n'avais pas d'ordi et les
fautes je m'amusais à refaire les
arborescences pour comprendre comment il
avait stocké oui savent que je range les
télécommandes dans l'ordre chez moi
d'accord ce genre de mec qui a fait un
scrabble tout seul un dimanche après
midi quand il pleut pas c'est ça et
essayer de comprendre comment ton
cerveau j'ai vraiment alors c'est moi le
mec se cherche encore tout seul en fait
tu sais claude françois disait chaque
détail compte
et après il a dit c'est ça au moins il a
rejoint la lumière tient et depuis
l'ambiance est électrique
on fait un battle on oublie akinator mon
père battait un battle de vannes on va
revenir sur akinator je vais le décalé
tu va l'écrire tu leur fais voir de près
les années quatre-vingt seize crois
l'avoir monde n'ait songé parvient de
bouquins frantic en même temps un petit
rhodia elle passe du gardien messin va
manquer moi j'ai plein de calle avec moi
si tu veux je te prie un cahier avant de
partir je m là comme ça tu peux
confirmer que je ne vois pas cet écran
ici là d'accord quand de contrôle occ et
toi tu l'écris de manière à lille
total fait voix rauque et qu'est ce
qu'on appelle là-bas a choqué tous
derrière toi sous un coup ce donc là je
suis censé marquer le prénom ou que le
nom de famille est la chose qui permet
le mieux l'identifier quoi d'accord
c'est la preuve d'accord donc vous le
saurez mais pas moi et je peux vous
assurer que je ne vois pas à l'écran de
retour de son autre histoire pas chez
take no doubt est encore prêt et sa part
maintenant parce que j'aurais dit pense
que je peux entendre le bruit créé onze
ans en fait il y avait un sourire c'est
bon alors attends maintenant je vais
enlever le papier la attend d'abord faut
que j'enlève le bouchon c'est très
compliqué tu sais j'ai pas fait d'études
donc très compliqué à reboucher un
bouchon voilà pour boucher un bouchon
2016 renault ont bien joué je
l'arrachent je le mange c'est ça ok je
le cache il n'y a plus rien vous l'avez
vu ce qu'il faut quand même savoir qui
est un public ici c'est ça fait tourner
toujours en public comme des sites comme
des gambier sitcoms comme ça quand il
fait une vague une bonne bien vers dans
le
vive le dit c'est alors un truc bête tu
voulais pas en même temps que je joue
akinator alors si j'aimerais bien que tu
le fasses etc et un convoi qui gagne ok
exactement après je vais faire du coup
je vais essayer de faire deviner avec
l'ina tort la même chose
ok d'accord ça roule bethesda envie de
prononcer le nom de nom pour ça je me
bloque je ne dis rien je ne lirai averse
a atteint un téléphone savourer mon
téléphone idées au nouveau dojo du
patriote je crains une coupe vas-y fais
fait la sienne n'avait pas de problème
ok je montre à la caméra nazis c'est
donc à la vendée c'est bon j'ai répondu
ok voici ma question est ce que c'est
une femme je pense que c'est une femme
pas pour la question que s'est posée de
la fed ajouté
alors alors j'ai besoin de confirmer oui
oui ok cool alors ensuite au caire à toi
vous avez vu que je le regarde pas parce
que eux ils savent que je déconne le non
verbal en permanence donc j'ai pas envie
de tricher je la joue au net
est ce que ces issues de l'univers des
écrans c'est à dire au sens large cinéma
youtube télévision oui ok ok est ce que
cette femme est fictive où est ce qu'on
parle d'une actrice d'une comédienne est
ce qu'on parle d'un nom propre et ce
qu'on parle d'un personnel attend
refaite à question du trop de bruit
derrière est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on parle
d'un personnage ou est ce qu'on parle de
l'actrice en elle même donc est ce qu'on
parle d'un personnage non non tu as une
deuxième question parce que je répondis
déjà une autre question d'akena tort
c'était tellement rapide c'est avoir la
technologie
est-ce que c'est ici série télévisée non
à troyes est-ce que la première lettre
du prénom absolument rien de ce qui
vient spontanément quand on pense à
cette personne est ce que la première
lettres dans l'alphabet est situé après
la lettre m
ou avant donc ma question c'est est ce
que c'est si tu apprécies tu as des
connaître son alphabet j'ai pas révisé
non plus un après après à toi akinator
et plus rapides à répondre mais voilà il
est moins fort que moi au final est-ce
que la première lettre
c'est un thé non
est ce que c'est un r oui
une proposition donc je vais l'écrire
ici donc là je n'ai pas encore à une
question
bah tu vas jusqu'au bout d'actine à tort
mais moi on sait que j'ai compte le
nombre de questions qu'il te poses
encourage ancien la 9e donc y en a une
la deuxième temps 20 j'attire je vous
fais voir je changerai pas -selon
akinator et je fais comme les bd je fais
comme ça pour compter 4
il doit c'est loin ouais je suis déjà
plus de six questions ça veut dire elle
est oui alors à qui tu pensais non je
veux d'abord je leur ai fait voir un jeu
pourrait pas changer je l'aï fait moi je
la fais voir ce que j'ai écrit il n'y
aura pas de changement possible
marc moreau vie je connais pas fait quoi
c'est celle qui a joué dans le dernier
film suicide squad beau robbie ouais je
vois pas facile mais j'ai parti à
t'énerves à fait juste remarquer robin
directement si ça dérange personne
est ce qu'on peut faire un petit
comparatif s'il vous plaît hop et or
comment c'est possible
j'ai pas vraiment un truc je veux ça
tu va proposer que deux lettres en fait
après je moi j'ai un avantage
calculateur n'aura jamais sur moi c'est
que c'est je vois le temps que tu mets
pas choisir quelqu'un dans ta tête je
vois le sourire que tu ailles ou pas je
connais l'actualité ou pas tu vois ce
que le dire je sais ce que tu as fait
plus ou moins dernièrement ou pas je
sais languit tonne me piéger ou pas et
après c'est juste un tacle boeuf aussi
quoi bon génique margot robbie c'était
égal à quelque chose sur mon surnom
papier ce que tu arrives si tu te
contentes sur moi ou autres est ce que
tu arrives g8 margot robbie
en gros quand tu pensé à elle ou quand
tu la voyais ça signifie quelque chose
j'allais me margot robbie est égal et
ensuite j'ai fait un petit signe en
dessous de ceux est égal c'est égal j'ai
écrit quelque chose est en dessous de ça
j'ai fait un petit signe donc voulu nous
faire rire exactement ça c'était obligé
exactement si j'étais petit bol chez big
apple profite on prend goût
mais non j'ai mis rouge vous avec un
coeur pour abc ouf j'ai battu akinator
ok on a la preuve ici même si question
après il l'avait toujours pas où fut
donc comme a franchement c'est ouf
comme quoi on a bouclé la barre ok
l'homme a créé l'intelligence
artificielle mais il ya quand même le
pouvoir de déduction sur lui s'il a jugé
en terminant je suis entièrement
d'accord là dessus mais c'est ouf quand
même 2 après lui il fonctionne avec une
base de données ne serait ce que tu
disais il fonctionne pas avec les
émotions avec l'actualité au début mai
et a dû quand même bien suivre mon
actualité pour sa fin je trouve ça enfin
deux questions concrètes c'était les
lettres et a proposé tu et à proposer
air direct après r il y avait plein
d'autres trucs de possible tu vois pas
franchement c'est bluffant fois ça plaît
aux agrafes cool c'est tellement content
d'avoir fait ça avec toi ça fait
longtemps en fait que je voulais faire
le battle et c'est pas mal en plus avec
toi c'était cool tu vois moi qui sais
pas trop utiliser les smartphones et
tout ça tu vois ça tombait bien comme ça
j'ai appris à utiliser cependant ce type
d'école bon cela fait ça s'appelle du
stock reading jeter 10 ans mentalisme je
vous ferai une vidéo là dessus sur le
stock reading c'est-à-dire de d'avoir un
gros paquet comme ça d'information et de
faire un entonnoir pour accéder à une
information geoffrey ça peut-être pas ce
dimanche là mais je vous ferai c'est un
dimanche sur comment sûr on va dire un
choix limité à sens donnez vous pouvez
en quelques questions trouver la donner
le personnage assez grave foule en tout
cas merci non ajustées pour nous
d'explorer en dessous c'est cool je
n'étais jamais venu comme ça du côté de
la croatie c'est vous j'ai vu c'est
magnifique on est en croisant les mecs
qui avaient eu c'est un peu dans un
appartement volant là on vient de passer
la bulgarie on redescend vers l'ukraine
ce soir en est rien sebastopol
traversent la mer noire en chine en
turquie
impeccable c'est l'endroit de géographie
que je peux dire merci beaucoup et si
jamais vous connaissez pas romain de la
chaîne techno un test techno et est je
vous invite
cliquez sur son visage et à regarder
dans le descriptif de mettre un lien
vers ta chaîne c'est une chaîne même
avec plaisir
cool si jamais vous ne connaissez pas
fabien puisque vous le retrouver grâce
au partage que vous avez de partout et
vu que vous avez vu sa petite tête là
toute mignonne que vous ne connaissez
pas non plus vous allez voir sa chaîne
et pour le coup vous êtes déjà dessus
mais pas vraiment donc à l'échangé et
vous allez voir les autres vidéos qu'il
a fait il a tourné aussi avec mon pote
qui pierre cros
oui on est vous avez fait des trucs cool
ensemble c'est comme ça qu'on s'est
connus semaine au mans et on iront
beaucoup d'enfants quoi peut peut-être
si jamais vous avez aimé la vidéo baisse
est cool et vous pouvez nous percevoir
la laisse un petit pouce en l'air vous
pouvez également vous abonner à la
chaîne avant de partir et rendez vous
demain à 17 heures ciao